biden expected to speak tonight after
jumping into the lead in some key
battleground states
which at the moment are too close to
call let's check in with peter ducey
from the latest of the biden campaign
peter
jesse good evening even though there's
been no final call yet uh
biden campaign staffer tells me that on
a conference call
this morning higher-ups were telling
biden staffers to enjoy
this moment and at this moment joe biden
remains at home that's where he's been
all day we haven't seen or heard from
him since yesterday's minute and 45
second long
speech and that's where he said
sometimes democracy is messy and
requires
patience which he hopes he gets from
campaign staffers and supporters
the biden campaign is paying very close
attention to the things
president trump is saying telling me
that his remarks last night were
desperate
baseless and a sure sign he's losing the
campaign is interpreting reports that
president trump has no plans to concede
as meaning
that he may not leave the white house by
the time that the lease is up at the end
of january
telling fox the u.s government has a lot
of experience removing trespassers from
the white house grounds
the campaign is confident enough that
they're on a glide path
to 270 electoral votes that officials
did not host
an on the record update about the way
they see the map shaking out like they
did yesterday and the day before
kamala harris still in town she is set
to speak first
if tonight's event moves forward and
there has been a noticeable
increase in security around here there's
also been a noticeable increase in the
number of curious locals who are walking
up to the secret service fence sticking
their phones through
trying to get a look at the set where
biden may
speak tonight all right thanks a lot
peter all right greg uh
looks like it's moving quickly over
there well i think um
i think joe's really lucky because if
the i mean he's lucky if the republicans
have the senate
because that's a supplemental spine and
he needs that
right that's a great point he needs it
and it's like when it when he starts to
teeter
or he loses his energy which could
happen the very first day
he can blame it on cocaine mitch and
everybody else and i think that's really
important and i think that americans
who voted for trump who feel down they
should be a bit relieved that that
there's a really good balance of power
here and and that's the way
our founders created this place is so
you
you win a little in every election and
this election
it's not going to change your life it's
not going to change your family life or
your love life or your
diet or your uh your fitness routine and
hopefully it won't change your job
it may for some people at cnn but we'll
be okay but the point is
if you were willing to trade any of
those positive elements of your life for
a better
for a different outcome in your election
you're not a real person
right dana how do you think team biden
has conducted itself
in the the days following the election i
i think
pretty well i am a little i'm a little
uncomfortable with tonight's speech i
feel like
that joe biden feeling like he needed to
be seen
at two o'clock in the afternoon or four
o'clock in the aftertune just to keep
everybody calm and keep
that seemed to make a lot of sense to me
nothing has changed from yesterday to
today
except for we have you know we don't
have any additional race calls
now i imagine when they announced that
there was going to be an evening speech
that they probably thought this thing
was going to be projected as a win for
them and that they would present
themselves as president and vice
president-elect that's not the case
so i think that it's just a little
curious to
have this right now but up to this point
i think that their comments have been
pretty good
what do you think biden's gonna say
tonight juan well i think as i said
earlier i think he will make it very
clear that
although he's not declaring victory and
he's aware of the court cases
he wants to move forward and plan for
the country he thinks that's
in the best interest of the american
people just in quick response so i would
say look the secret service today
sealed the airspace over biden's house
they have increased as you just heard
from peter ducey their presence
around biden their job is to protect the
president
and the next president and i think
judged uh on their
actions today you can see that they what
they think about the state of this race
final thoughts sagan all joe biden has
to do is sit back
just lay down on his sheds and try to
figure out how to claim
uh lay claim to the vaccines that are
going to come
the economy right the vaccines we're
going to have
three maybe that are approved in january
again operation warp speed
who laid that plan in place president
trump and then the economy
we're back below seven percent on
unemployment it took seven
months it took four and a half years
after the 2009 recession ended
for it to fall below that mark under
obama and biden
all he has to do is nothing don't raise
taxes the economy is improving
let people get back to work and you can
just have somebody feed you grapes
greg i'd love to do that luckiest
politician in america
nobody